[Music]
for me the most important thing is the
story that I'm telling whether it's a
scary set piece or a dramatic moment it
all comes down to the characters and if
you care about them Aquaman is very
powerful but what drives him comes from
a very human place his story it
resonated with me instantly
it's not accepted here not really
accepted here definitely can identify
with that
I fell in love with the project and fell
in love with Mira she's no damsel in
distress she's gonna strong badass
empowered superhero with Aquaman a trick
and also put up a fun is designing a
whole different world that we've never
seen before you're pretty much is
limited by your own imagination it's
just a whole lot of magic on this
project once they put all these things
together behind James's vision blows my
mind still the appeal of it was to step
into something else
you really are invigorated because a
very good experience all these amazing
worlds we haven't been under the ocean
yet this is our outer space I keep going
back to that inherent fascination that
we have with the ocean and if it turned
on you
just the sheer vastness and the mystery
of it there's still a lot we don't know
I've always known that I wanted to it
accent movie I'll get to be a big kid on
the playground and cause trouble blow
things up your body is constantly
working
you don't judo jujitsu fight
choreography at four and a half months
stunt training six days a week
you feel pretty superhuman I get to
present Aquaman the wool in this really
badass and cool way we have never seen
this on screen and that's that's the
truth get a fall in love with the idea
what it's like to have these powers be a
kid that's fun for the family it's fun
for everyone we want to create something
interesting
no want the standard James Wan can't do
the sander
any great superhero story should make
you feel that you've learned something
from these characters and you yourself
have the ability to do good and you
don't need a cape to be able to do that
my parents were from different worlds
and that was a product of the love that
never should have been could unite our
worlds one day a son of the land and a
son of the Seas
my mother always knew you were special
you are part of something deeper
you are the breech true hand and see
your rightful place
is king
[Music]
we're getting close now oh yeah what's
the wife buying a thirst
there's no way Atlantis with this far
inland
check this place out
it's real
[Music]
nothing of course it's not working it's
been sitting here collecting dust since
before the Sahara was a desert before
the Sahara was a desert let's just say
you do your best thinking when you're
not thinking at all right now hold still
hey what are you doing we need water
you're the closest source
[Music]
sure I could've just peed on it
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis
my power journey beyond the edge of the
world to the hidden sea
in the wrong hands
it would bring destruction
was in the hands of the true heir
it would unite all our kingdoms above
and below
what should we have written it down
first I memorized it didn't you oh yeah
what did you say something-something
Trident the Beast has awakened
the time has come
for Atlantis to rise again
[Music]
oh is awesome
you are not going to win this
billions will die unless you help us
I'm no leader
and not King
[Music]
he's always had a king now I need
something more
what could be greater than I can
[Music]
a hero
[Music]